نعم فعلا هو صحيح ليش لان احنا لما نتحدث
عن همم
القوه اللي تملكها الرياضه يعني الرياضه
لها قوه وقوه خفيه همم لها تاثير وهي
تمثيل اصلا سياسي بمعنى او باخر هي تمثل
دوله هي مراه
لتعكس نظره او هويه المجتمع لنفسه ليس فقط
همم صورته امام العالم ولكن ايضا لنفسه
اذا كان هناك نوع من الانجازات نوع من
الانتصارات فهذه تشكل يعني صوره خاصه
الفوز السعودي على الارجنتين في هذه
المرحله في هذه اللحظه اللي تشهد فيها
السعوديه
الانطلاقه همم وزخم جديد مع الرؤيا ومع
يعني
حتى الشعارات اللي تلاحظين الفعاليات كلها
زي مثلا موسم الرياض فوق الخيال وتخيل
اكثر وهكذا كلمه الامير محمد طموحنا يعانق
عنان السماء وهمتنا مثل جبل الطويق ربما
يكون ما جرى يعكس هذا الامر لكن اذا
تاذنين للدكتور موسى سنكمل الحديث حول هذا
الامر فقط بعد فاصل وجيز فلا تذهب بعيدا
مازال لنا شغف مع الرياضه وكره القدم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حديثنا كان وما يزال عن
كره القدم اثرها وسحرها
ومحركاتها الاجتماعيه والسياسيه وايضا
الاقتصاديه بحكم انه صناعه لكن ليس حدودنا
اليوم على الاقتصاد بل عن سحر هذه الرياضه
واثرها همم شركاء الندوه كان وما يزال هنا
في الاستديو والدكتوره منى الغريبي
الاكاديميه السعوديه في جامعه الملك سعود
وعضو الجمعيه السعوديه للدراسات
الاجتماعيه من دبي دكتور موسى برهومه همم
عضو التدريس في الجامعه الامريكيه حياكم
الله واياكما دكتوره منى كنت تتحدثين عن
انه الرياضه ونحن نتحدث عن كره القدم هنا
كما انها تعكس رؤيه الاخرين لنا يعني ايضا
تعكس رؤيته رؤيتنا لانفسنا لذواتنا فنحن
نلعب ونؤدي كما نرى انفسنا في المكان الذي
نستحقه فهذا ينطبق مثلا انا الرياضه
السعوديه والمنتخب السعودي لكره القدم انه
يحاول ان
يتوائم مع الليفل او الخط او المستوى الذي
وصلت اليه رؤيه 2030
بالحقيقه انه هذه العمليه هي عمليه
مترابطه ما حصل في الكره السعوديه بالامس
وفوزه على الارجنتين ما هو الا كتابه فصل
جديد في تاريخ السعوديه الحديث
ما حصل هي همم عمليه همم خروج من الاطار
التقليدي الى همم يعني همم
مجال اكثر تنمويه واكثر طموح واكثر
استعداد
للمستقبل يعني الان احنا رؤيه 2030 بقياده
سمو الامير محمد بن سلمان حقيقه ما هي الا
ان نقله نوعيه همم للوطن في عمليه انتقال
هذا ما حصل في الرياضه هو همم تابع
للمسيره تابع للاجراءات تابع
للتحول الوطني
سمو الامير همم
ومن تحته من همم مسؤولين همم للامل على
همم يعني رفع شان المملكه وصورتها امام
العالم اولا وعم امام انفسنا
يعني جزء من كل منطقه